[Music]
coming up on 5 25 on your Wednesday
morning we've got a new angle on why
some drivers are leaving Big spaces in
front of them at stop lights
from repeated concerns about not wanting
to get rear-ended like Christian writing
defensive driving courses suggest that
the added space avoids additional damage
to the car in front of you if you do get
rear-ended and Natalie writing people
are crazy I like to leave enough room so
I can get away in an emergency but
here's the Twist from Anne who writes I
was told by AAA many years ago to allow
enough room to escape in the event
someone tries to carjack you or there's
gunfire or similar danger in your area
and David saying in these times
carjacking is a reality if you have more
space you have more room to escape
hadn't heard that one before now outside
of texters who are not paying attention
it sounds like most people leaving Big
spaces and stop lights have their
reasons and as long as they don't keep
you from safely getting through the
signal maybe we can let it go thanks
again to Kristen Natalie and David
everyone who has chimed in buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversations an easy email address
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com